cuál es el área de la figura sombreada
así que acá abajo tenemos esta figura
sombreada de color verde y se ve como un
rectángulo excepto porque tiene un
cuadrado vacío en medio entonces para
encontrar su área tenemos que pensar
justo en eso si queremos saber cuánto
espacio cubre
bueno pues cubre toda el área de este
rectángulo sin este cuadrado entonces lo
que podemos hacer es encontrar el área
del rectángulo grande y a esta área
cortarle o más bien restarle el área del
cuadrado que tenemos aquí adentro para
así obtener el área de la figura
sombreada de verde
así que empecemos y vamos a empezar
encontrando el área del rectángulo
grande es decir esta área que tengo aquí
voy a empezar a buscar esta área de este
rectángulo que tengo aquí y para eso
vamos a fijarnos en sus lados si
observas uno de sus lados tiene una
longitud de 9 centímetros y otro tiene
una longitud de 8 centímetros
entonces para encontrar el área de este
rectángulo de rosa tenemos que
multiplicar 9 por 8 y eso me va a dar 9
por 8 es 72 72 centímetros cuadrados eso
significa que todo este rectángulo que
tengo aquí que todo en este rectángulo
que tengo aquí tiene un área de 72
centímetros cuadrados o 72 centímetros
cuadrados cubren todos
este rectángulo de color rosa bien pero
ahora necesitamos cortar o restar este
cuadrado que tenemos aquí adentro así
que vamos a agarrar a este cuadrado
vamos a encontrar su área y vamos a
restar la de estos 72 centímetros
cuadrados y para hacerlo sabemos que
estos lados miden 4 centímetros 4
centímetros este y 4 centímetros así que
podemos pensarlo como cuatro centímetros
aquí cuatro centímetros aquí y también
de este lado cuatro centímetros así que
si unimos todas estas líneas todas estas
líneas y después uno esta línea que
tengo aquí y después esta que tengo aquí
y ahora para arriba esta que tengo aquí
y esta que tengo aquí te vas a dar
cuenta que tenemos cuatro columnas aquí
una
3 4 4 columnas de 1 2 3 4 centímetros
cuadrados entonces eso nos da 4 columnas
de 4 centímetros cuadrados cada una
eso es lo mismo que 16 centímetros
cuadrados es decir que necesitamos
quitar 16 centímetros cuadrados del área
del rectángulo grande de 72 centímetros
cuadrados de toda esta área vamos a
restar estos 16 centímetros cuadrados
así que vamos a hacerlo si a estos 72
centímetros cuadrados del rectángulo
original 72 centímetros cuadrados del
rectángulo original le quitamos y
primero vamos a quitarle 10 de estos
cuadrados haciendo esto va a ser más
fácil la resta 10 centímetros cuadrados
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
nueve diez de ellos
bueno pues voy a obtener 62 centímetros
cuadrados y si ahora a esos 62
centímetros cuadrados le quitamos estos
2 estos 2 voy a llegar a am 60
centímetros cuadrados muy bien y si
ahora a estos 60 centímetros cuadrados
le quito los últimos 4 centímetros
cuadrados a esto le quitó 4 más voy a
llegar a 56 56 centímetros cuadrados es
decir que si el área total de 72
centímetros cuadrados le quitamos el
área del cuadrado de 16 centímetros
cuadrados nos queda un área final de 56
56 centímetros cuadrados
y esa es el área de la figura sombreada